what's going on guys this is rob and for
our video on beyond omega level today we
are returning to the world of marvel
cosmic and we're discussing the stranger
and of course this request comes from a
member of our honor guard over at
patreon so the stranger's origin is
somewhat shrouded in mystery but we'll
go over what it is that we know about
him so the stranger was created by stan
lee and jack kirby and made his debut in
issue number 11 of x-men in 1965 as one
of the earlier antagonists for the team
now what we know about him is that he's
a sort of cosmic scientist and explorer
that becomes curious about earth when he
learns of the presence of superpowered
beings on the planet and so he travels
to earth in order to study them now when
he gets here the stranger encounters the
x-men and the brotherhood of evil
mutants and he kidnaps magneto and toad
to take to his lab to experiment on now
later the stranger decides that humanity
was a threat to the omniverse and that
they all needed to die so he hatches a
few schemes to try and kill them all so
the first thing the stranger does is he
tries to control the hulk's mind and
convince him to destroy the planet but
bruce banner is able to convince the
stranger to abort this plan on another
occasion the stranger decides to wipe
out all life on earth with a device
called the no life bomb but the plans
thwarted by the silver surfer and a
scientist named al harper who was killed
while defusing the bomb now after seeing
this act of sacrificial heroism the
stranger decides that humans have the
capacity for good and that maybe he
doesn't have to kill them all and so for
his first few appearances this is what
the stranger was he would show up try to
destroy the earth and ultimately fail
but later we would learn the stranger is
one of the strongest cosmic entities in
mobile comics if not the single most
powerful guy that you've never heard of
now as far as where the stranger comes
from he claims that he was born of the
collective energy of an intellect of a
race that was being inhabited by the
planet gigantis now after the planet was
conquered the stranger became curious
about the existence of other life
throughout the universe and sets out to
learn as much about it as he possibly
can on one occasion the living tribunal
stated that he offered the stranger a
chance to be his fourth face but the
stranger refused for some unknown reason
to us so living tribunal was left with
this big empty spot on one side of his
head where his fourth face should be but
the living tribunal is said to be second
only to the one above all within the
marvel universe so the fact that he
found this stranger worthy of being one
aspect of his being as opposed to
somebody like oblivion or eternity or
any of the other cosmic entities shows
just how far up in the power hierarchy
this guy is now given that bit of
context it's not surprising that the
stranger possesses a ridiculous array of
powers and feats despite the limited
number of appearances that he's made the
stranger has many superhuman attributes
including strength sufficient enough to
match the god pluto in his own realm and
speed greater than that of quicksilver
or the silver surfer the stranger has
demonstrated an incredible level of
durability by sustaining attacks from
some of the most powerful characters of
the marvel universe he survived an
attack from adam warlock and the gardner
while both were in possession of
infinity stones he's unhurt by an energy
blast from the silver surfer and is
unaffected by a blast of hellfire from
the ghost rider the scarlet witch one of
the most powerful magic users in marvel
comics was unable to overpower the
stranger despite being at the peak of
her power suggesting that he has an
inherent resistance to magical attacks
but the most impressive example of the
stranger's durability is that he
survived an influx of energy from the
infinity union a device that contained
enough energy to create a multiverse now
this feat is also a testament to the
stranger's regenerative healing factor
which is so powerful that he can
re-materialize himself after splitting
himself apart on a molecular level which
means that harming the stranger with any
lasting effect is practically impossible
now in terms of offense the stranger is
able to fire powerful energy blasts
capable of knocking out juggernaut or
changing the orbit of the moon when
working in tandem with galactus and eon
the stranger was able to temporarily
hold off thanos wielding the infinity
gauntlet one of the most powerful
weapons in marvel comics in addition to
forming blast the stranger can
manipulate energy on an insane level
even being able to rip the power cosmic
directly out of the silver surfer the
stranger is able to manipulate time and
matter he's created and subsequently
obliterated a planet can shrink and
increase the size of himself and others
and phase through both solid matter and
energy his manner manipulation is so
advanced that he was responsible for the
creation of ego the living planet and
his brother alter ego not only can he
create ordinary matter but his creations
are sentient and in this case extremely
powerful in their own right now since
ego himself is way beyond an omega level
threat the fact that it was the stranger
who created him definitely puts him on
an even higher level now the stranger is
both telekinetic and telepathic
demonstrating strong enough telepathy to
resist a psychic attack from the
overmind one of the eternals whose
psychic power comes from the combined
psyches of billions of eternals which
simply put means he's one of the
strongest telepaths in the multiverse
furthermore one of the watchers remarks
that the stranger's telepathy would be
able to break his mind if he had not
surrendered now the stranger possesses
cosmic awareness likely due in part to
the many experiments he's conducted
throughout the cosmos his knowledge is
so vast that he's sought out by the
watchers a race of beings whose literal
existence is nothing but watching and
recording what goes on in the universe
they saw this guy out for help on how to
cure a disease that was plaguing them
suggesting they regard him as one of the
most knowledgeable entities in all of
existence so yeah the stranger is
probably one of the most powerful beings
that you've never heard of from marvel
comics and he's always underestimated
right people sleep on the power of the
stranger probably because you just
haven't really seen him all that much
right he hasn't really done enough to
really fully utilize the totality of his
power but i will tell you this this
stranger at full power this guy is a
monster right this guy's power level is
absolutely insane but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace
you